michel nadeau entre en journalisme aux
devoirs en 1973 diplômé en sciences
politiques et titulaire d'un mba de
l'université laval l'économie devient sa
spécialité très vite il se fait
connaître de ses collègues journalistes
qui font appel à lui à titre d'expert ou
en irlande ou dans le sud des états unis
je ne crois pas que ce soit d un endroit
où la situation politique peut
éventuellement à être beaucoup plus
stable qu'elle loue québec au canada
fier nationaliste choqué du mépris des
élites torontoise pour l'économie du
québec il veut participer à son essor et
il décide de mettre en vedette les
entreprises québécoises à succès ces
hommes d'affaires etc financier qui
formeront ce qu'on appellera le québec
inc et en français c'est ainsi qu'après
10 ans au devoir il entre à la caisse de
dépôt et placement du québec à
l'invitation de son président jean
campeau et de son slogan faisons des
québécois un peuple de propriétaire
il occupe diverses fonctions à la haute
direction de la caisse dont celle de
président de cdp capital la recherche de
rendement maximum et de l'essor
économique du québec ont été le moteur
de grandes transactions comme celle de
la vente de provigo loblaws celle de
vidéotron à quebecor et non à rogers
confier votre mandat de diriger la
caisse de défaut sous la présidence de
jean-claude chrtr la caisse ouvre des
bureaux à l'étranger pour l'expertisé la
connaissance de l'international au ceci
rassure les investisseurs qui voient que
la politique monétaire est bien gérée
michel nadeau quitte la caisse en 2002
trois ans plus tard avec yvan allaire il
crée l'igopp l'institut sur la
gouvernance d'organisations privées et
publiques un organisme unique qui offre
des recherches sur les entreprises
cotées en bourse et des conseils de
gouvernance à des entreprises ou des
organismes divers soit prise d'un du
corps aux analyses sont recherchés est
offerte avec générosité à ses anciens
collègues journalistes michel nadeau
bonjour on changerait ses chroniques
régulières de l'émission samedi et rien
d'autre avec joël le bigot vont durer
cinq ans il passe en revue le parcours
du québec en matière d'économie depuis
60 ans
les produits qu'on a fait durant 60 ans
sont à fixes trop donné comme notre
place et pour lire aux jeunes regardez
là on est parti de l'an 59 qui a été une
belle aventure
63 chance au québec dans ses succès il y
à du michel nadeau jean michel leprince
sera du canada montréal